Sharing some of my favorite big sister tips slash advice.
No. 1 if you're dating a guy
and you're confused about the way he feels about you,
cut it off. Ended he does not like you,
don't waste any more of your time and move on.
Men are not complicated at all.
They usually know immediately
whether or not they are attracted to a girl
and like her. And if you are dating,
it will take a man practically no time to fall in love with you
if he's going to fall in love with you.
If you are in a situationship,
it is time to grow up and step away from that.
Situationships are not real relationships
and they most of the time end and nothing happens with them.
They're just a waste of time.
Survey after survey shows men prefer dresses over pants.
Take that information how you would.
However, if you're sitting there thinking well,
why would I care what a man thinks?
You might want to re evaluate that mindset.
Especially if you are married or you wish to be married.
Now that doesn't mean a pair of pants can't be feminine.
That is so far from the truth.
However, my favorite thing about dresses is that all you need is one
clothing garment
and you can style it up with jewelry,
hair, accessories. And you just can't be a beautiful feminine dress.
No. 3 if you are eating this and you are constantly hungry
and You think you just have a big stomach?
Stop eating this.
This non fat, zero calorie sweetener,
artificially flavored yogurt does not do anything for you.
If you want something that's actually gonna fill you up,
throw that junk out and swap it for a good quality whole milk yogurt.
Bonus points if you get the one with the cream on top.
Why yes, it is over double the amount of calories.
However, this kind of fat is so good for you,
especially if it is good quality.
And I don't know when fat suddenly became something bad.
And if you want it to be flavored,
flavor it with real fruit,
not artificial fruit.
You want it sweet,
use maple syrup or honey.
No. 4. If happy wife, happy life has a place in your marriage.
Stop that. Stop that.
That puts the wife on a pedestal
and it prioritizes the wife's needs and wants above the husbands.
And that is not how marriage works.
Happy husband,
happy wife, happy life.
And lastly, number five,
if you are ever feeling down,
something has just got you sad.
I have this method.
Go outside in the sunlight.
Or even if it's raining or snowing, whatever,
just go outside and feel the weather,
feel the elements,
feel the fresh air.
Come inside.
Um, eat something,
something you enjoy.
But that is healthy.
Maybe it's fruit with dark chocolate on top. Or, um,
a smoothie. Just something you enjoy and disconnect from technology.
No TV in the background,
no music and headphones.
No news. And just take a step back.
This will resent to you.
And it has worked so many times for me.
Um, so, yeah,
definitely give that a shot if you are ever feeling down.
So those are my 5 big sister tips slash advice.
And this is really fun.
I really wanna do it again.
And I hope you enjoy. Bye.